[Applause]
you know Howie Mandel would only jump on
top of a table for a truly truly special
act 21 year old Joseph Allen had no idea
just how crazy things would get when he
auditioned for season 14 of America's
Got Talent
I see myself as being someone who can
make a major impact in the world and I
just want to see how much of a footprint
I can leave on earth before I leave the
singer immediately won over the judges
with his kind heart and charisma but it
was his performance of an original song
he wrote that sealed the deal
[Music]
[Music]
but today
the world's gonna know me I just feel so
grateful that now we get a chance to be
here and be a part of I don't know just
making making dreams a reality for these
contestants I love being a part of
making dreams come true it's nice to be
a part of saying yes to someone's dreams
all four judges gave Joseph a standing
ovation and Howie Mandel took it a step
farther proving just how much he
believes in him
[Applause]
Joseph is the second contestant this
season to earn a golden buzzer the first
was Cody Lee I love singing Cody is a 22
year old singer who's blind and autistic
and clearly has the gift of music
[Music]
Cody and his mom Tina stopped by ET one
week after his stellar audition they
opened up about their AGT experience so
far how exciting was it for you to be on
that stage and sing for the judges it
was though were you nervous at all no
I'm happy now what was it like for you
mom and for the family really to see
Cody get that kind of reaction from the
judges also the golden buzzer well first
shock I mean even though you know even
though we know like his talent is just
amazing still you know you run into a
lot of things during his whole life of
the music you run into a lot of I don't
know if it's called stigma or whatever
it's called but you run into where a lot
of people when you say yeah he's
autistic and blind and then you know
they kind of have that face like oh okay
you know like singing right but then he
would blow them away so it was really
shocking for us because it was nice to
see you know the the judges just fall in
love with him and to really see his
talent
[Applause]
[Music]